الان هذه الصور حيث تشهد السفاره السويديه
بالعراق
احتجاجا على السماحل السياسي متطرف بحرق
نسخه من المصحف الشريف
احتجاجات قرب السفاره السويديه في العراق
كما ذكرنا في العاصمه بغداد اتجاجا على
قيام سياسي سويديا متطرف بحق نسخه من
المصحف الشريف من القران الكريم قبل ايام
هي اذا الحادثه التي اثارت السلطه اا
الشعوب المسلمه التي احتجت على احراق
المصحف الشريف امام في السويد اذا كان
ذكرنا وها هي تخرج مظاهرات اذا في همم
امام السفاره السويديه في العراق احتجاجا
على ما قام به
السياسيون سويدي قطر
في هذا الجانب من الصور كما تبدو
التعزيزات الامنيه حول مقر السفاره
للحيلوله دون اقتحام المتظاهرين لمقر
السفاره كما يبدو بنظر الى هذا التجمع همم
لعراقيين
يحتجون امام مقر السفاره السويديه في
بلادهم العراق احتجاجا على احراق نسخه من
المصحف الشريف السويد قبل ايام
وتحاول قوات المناعه الاولى دون وصولهم
الى مقر السفاره منقرضون من المقر في
الحقيقه لكن عندما تحاول قوات الامن العام
[تصفيق]
استمرونا اذا في متابعه هذه الصور من امام
السفاره السويديه في العراق
لهذه المظاهره الاحتجاجيه التي يعبر فيها
اذا العراقيون عن غضبهم من الخطوه التي
قام بها سياسيون سويديو متطرف قام باحراق
نسخه من المصحف الشريف هذه
الخطوه التي اثارت ردود فعل غاضبه في عدد
من الدول ادنها ايضا سياسيون سويديون
ولكن ربما الغضب ما زال مستمرا بالنظر الى
خطوره هذه الخطوه والغضب الذي
تركب عنها في اوصاف المسلمين الذين يعبرون
يوميا رفع التواصل الاجتماعي كما نتابع عن
غضبهم من هذه الخطوه
التي استعجلها كما ذكرنا
سياسيون في كل انحاء العالم والسياسيون
السويديون كان رئيس الوزراء السويدي قد
عبر عن
ربما عن غضبه ايضا من هذه الخطوه
واستنكرها ايضا واداناها
تلك الخطوه اذا التي قام بها
سياسي يمني في ستوكهولم قبل ايام عندما
قام باحراق نسخه من المصحف الشريف
تقدري ان يلتحق بنا مراسلنا من بغداد
ليضعنا
في تفاصيل هذا المشهد الذي نتابعه من
زاويه واحده لنتمكن من خلالها ربما من
مشاهده
التظاهره والاحتجاج بكل تفاصيله في انتظار
اي ينضم الينا نستمر اذا في متابعه هذا
المباشر من امام السفاره السويديه في
العراق وهذه المظاهره الاحتجاجيه التي
يخرج فيها العراقيون
غاضبين من احراق سويدي يميني متطرف لي
نسخه من المصحف الشريف في السويد قبل ايام
الشرطه العراقيه تطوق هذا المكان
وتحاول منع المتظاهرين من الاقتراب من مقر
السفاره هم على بعد خطوات من المقر في
الحقيقه ولكن ربما الحيله دون اقتحام
المقر نظرا للغضب الكبير والاستهجان
الكبير في وسط هؤلاء من ما قام به
السياسي السويدي